يختلفوا معها كثيرون بسبب ارائها الكرويه
المتعصبه فهي ليست مجرد مشجعه بل تنتقد
اللاعبين وتلقي جام غضبها على المدربين
سماحه صلاح 11 المشجعات لكره القدم في
السودان يتابعها كثيرون من رواد مواقع
التواصل ويتفاعلون معها سلبا وايجابا
احيانا تواجه الانتقادات بسبب رفض البعض
دخول المراه مجال كره القدم لعبا او حتى
لتشجيعها لكن سماحه من اسره الرياضيه
معروفه فهي حفيده لاعب الهلال السوداني
السابق مكي اسماعيل
اقسم بالله التعبشر المدرب مر على تاريخ
الهلال يقع عليك الله بتخري يا اخي خير من
الزوراني يا اخي استغفر الله العظيم
الا المريخ بتخلي المريخ
الكره المستديره عشقي لكره القدم من جدي
مكيدريسا لاعب الهلال السوداني ورثنا حب
الهلال اا خلانا كيف نحب الهلال السوداني
العظيم اها طيب يا سماحه انت اسمك سماحه
بس عندك تعصب كروي وكيف
الهلال الهلال
همم الكره ما بيحلى الجو الكوره الا لما
يكون في اشخاص متعصبين كله فريق عنده خصم
من المشجعين بيحضروا مع بعض بتكون سهله
بدنا نفهم منك يعني الكثير بينتقد البنات
لما يشوفوا المباراه
اه صراحه في السودان هو نازل ثلج يعني
تلاقي بنات بيحضروا الكوره بيتعصبوا للكره
كانت يعني ما حدا سهل انه تطلعي وتتكلمي
وتنتخبي اللعيبه وتتكلم عن المدرب فحتى في
مشجعين كانوا
بنستقدوا الحاجه دي انه كيف بتطلع وتتكلم
لكن طبعا الهلال ففي ناس بعد ذلك الحكايه
لانه انا من اسره
الان في سودانيات يعني كثار بيشجعوا بيشجع
الكوره بيشجع المنتخبات بيطلع وبيتكلموا
زي زمان طيب اذا ما زي زمان انت يا سماح
تلعبي فوتبول هيك هوايه
كانت ايجابيه او سلبيه يعني همم الردود
دخلت التشكيله لكن في مرات بتستدعي ان انا
نطلع ونتكلم
عيني لعبت الهلال بدي اخر مباراه تثبتوني
الفوز يدخل في الميدان اخر مباراه ديونا
من هناك قالبينوا تفرحونا وتمسحوا الحاجات
الحزينه من الموسم الفاط والحاجات دي كلها
عايزين كلنا زي هيفاء مصطفى
غير كده والله